options I could have also in this kind
of breaks and evenings so now I'm going
to present you some results we have
about some methods reconstruct past
demographic history and contrary to
previous talks to be more like some kind
of empirical results and more like an
empirical or publish it yet exist and so
this is some work that was done in
collaboration with several people listed
here and it will be about inference from
the site frequency spectrum so I guess
you all know about the Collison process
we had civil talked about this but just
dislike just to show you that actually
if you have different publishing history
so this is some kind of constant
regulations and vision that went through
some kind of recent expansion and if you
had some recent population contraction
then you will expect to have very
different Collison trees and of course
if you add on to these some mutations
actually both the number of mutations
and the frequencies of these mutations
will also vary depending on these
different demographic sure scenarios so
one thing that you can do is to try to
summarize the pattern of diversity by
just looking at the distribution of the
allele frequencies of the in the
population and that's what is usually
called the site frequency spectrum so on
these axes you have the frequency of the
different mutations yep let's do the
other frequencies and hits the number of
sites at which you see this kind of a
net frequency so in star shape
populations you have this kind of nice
exponential decay of these cypresses
spectrum and if you have expansions you
have a lot of sites are very low
frequencies and if you have resumed the
exact you have a much more even
population so there is a lot of
information you can't actually get from
this sexual spectrum in single
populations and you can extend this kind
of game by considering the Giants I
tweakin spectrum we're actually here in
models that involved
two populations or more in that case in
some kind of isolation with migration
model where you have some miss repulsion
that split into two populations and
these two populations selections of
migrants in this case it's a bit a
symmetric somehow you would expect
depending on the directions time or the
migration rate between sufficient to see
different joint second seat spectra okay
so on this axis you have a frequency in
one population on this axis you have the
any frequency in the ventilation and the
color scheme corresponds to the
different number of sites that have
these joint frequencies so there's a lot
of information you can use to try to
actually given these joint cycling
spectra to reconstruct a bit the history
of these if these populations so but as
was mentioned before you have a bit
discours of this excitation spectrum as
was shown by Sen mayor's performin and
Nick Patterson actually we're actually
you can have different demographic
histories that can lead to exactly the
site same a site frequency spectrum and
in that case just show different example
but just just took one so here you have
time and here you have just to conserve
population that can vary in size and if
you have this kind of strange history
that goes up and down somehow you would
expect to see the same subjects to exam
as if you had a constant population size
okay so it seems I think the debate is
still a bit open to which extent we can
really reliably infer the past history
from sapphic spectrum and there could be
some kind of non-identity ability of
problems in some cases but despite this
actually many people have tried to still
use this septic system and relatively
successfully in some cases and one of
the most commonly used method is this
symmetric developed by Putin kunst in
them
croatian with different people and
carlos bustamante so this program daddy
which is using diffusion approximation
to get the expected cyclic inspection in
models that involve up to three
populations that can diverge and share
migrants have instances and mixture and
relatively complex scenarios and this
has been a bit the the most commonly
used method to make the scatter
inference and actually I've been trying
to develop some matter that could be a
natural teeth to this method there
because I wanted to try to estimate
scenario that involves a bit more than
three populations a bit more complex
scenarios and there was some kind of
problems for inferring this demography
in these more complex and I use using
using daddy so much steel the user
decides that system is is interesting
for negation sequencing data because
somehow you can have huge amount of data
and the inference is basically doesn't
does not depend on there's not depend on
the amount of data that you have so you
can have 10 mega bases hundred egg aviso
full genome somehow you just have more
precision on this site resi spectrum and
sweet scales well with the amount of
data so i think it fits well for these
kind of gingers data sets the nice thing
also is that these methods can be used
to study very complex scenario as i
mentioned with preparation divergences
migrations different population sizes
bottlenecks expansions actually in
scenarios that were before this kind of
daddy program well the reserve to maybe
approximate values and computation
methods but now we can do that with this
site messy spectrum and actually and
these summations are somehow very fast
and could be obtained in minutes hours
or a few days compared to ABC of full
likelihood method that would require
weeks or months of computations
so this seems all good but still there
are some problems related to the use of
this site wanksta spectrum and one of
the problem is this you can get the some
likelihood but somehow to maximize this
likelihood is not always very trivial so
and this has to do with different
problems and mentioned here then but
sometimes the approximation after that
is used is not optimal and sometimes we
can have some kind of conversion program
to get to the global optimum and
something that also we don't have is an
information about Lincoln's aquarium so
it just assumed that all the sites are
independent which is another case and to
obtain rapidly good values usually you
need to repeat estimations from
different starting point to be sure that
you find this kind of global maximum
likelihood of composite likelihood since
it is a complete likely because you
don't take into account this this
linkage is graham there so what else
only need is I said it's good to have it
can be applied to larger I said actually
you need also some larger sets to apply
this kind of method so you cannot have
gene-specific estimations for these
converters because you just don't have
enough polymorphic sides in a given gene
to apply these kilometers so usually you
are just trying to estimate genome-wide
specific or maybe potentially chromosome
specific estimates but it's difficult to
have really estimations on precise
regions or too short regions okay so
that's maybe one problem then another
very important problem is that I said
okay it's good to have an extra gene
sequencing data but sometimes if you
have low coverage then you tend to
underestimate the low frequency variants
and i showed you somehow that in some
cases these low freakin variants have a
precise signatures for sunday graphic
scenarios so somehow if you miss those
annette those low pregnancy variance
then you are likely to actually have
wrong inferences about the process area
of populations so so some care needs to
be done to be used to correct infer the
circling spectrum and different methods
some developed by Rasmus some wife is
acutely and Hannigan that try to give
some maximum likelihood estimation with
the sacred spectrum and that and then we
can somehow plug these things after that
into these influential programs so okay
so yeah I will just a bit show you a bit
the framework that I've been using to
try to reconstruct these expected siping
seconds actually it's just based on this
very nice idea of Erasmus in this paper
of 2000 why actually showed that these
entries of the Southwest section can be
just obtained as some kind of ratios of
expected branch lengths of the
coalescent 3 so for instance suppose
that you have a koala century like this
and you would like to estimate what is
the expected frequency for mutation that
would have a narrow frequency of to
basically this formula just says that
actually is just the ratio of the sum of
the branch lengths on which a mutation
would lead to two terminal nodes over
the total three lengths okay so somehow
these entries would just be the sum of
these red branches over the total three
lengths and this is what you should get
an expectation but actually you can easy
use simulations to try to approximate
these this probability by just
performing lots of simulations and just
summing actually all these branch
lengths over all simulations and / this
all the total branch lengths to get some
expected entries in your SMS and of
course the more simulations you use the
marcher this estimation can be that's
really nice because this can be applied
to any kind of scenario and this can be
of course extended to an arbitrary
number of populations so and then once
we have this expected cycling spectrum
it's relatively easy to come up with
some likelihood and where you just
actually in this case some kind of
multinomial likelihood that was proposed
by an absent hudson some daddy actions
using a different likelihood more pass
on light but somehow they are some
Abbott equivalent and in this likelihood
what you have here is this p 0 which is
the protein that there is no mutation on
the tree and and add the power of the
number of malefic sites in your sequence
times the fruity there is some kind of
mutation new tree at the power of the
number of polymorphic sites in your
sequence and then you just have this
kind of product of the disability nebula
perficient's ok so that's a very simple
likelihood and you can in this case also
use this proportion of monomorphic
versus prime of excites to somehow
calibrate all the three lengths and D to
get some absolute values for all these
drug events divergence types of
population sizes ok so and then what we
did was just to implement all this kind
of machinery into some kind of program
that would be roughly easy to use which
was an extension of some kind of
simulation program that i developed a
few years ago and so we are just using
question simulations to estimate this I
20 spectrum and we use in principle
large number of simulations to a point
to estimate it and to get likelihood and
the problem might be sometimes that
when you have very large numbers of
parameters the price to actually up team
at to get optimal likelihood and for
this with instead of having some
procedure that tries to optimize all
price at a time we have some simple
version of this which is called this
kind of a conditional expectation
maximization scenario algorithm that
actually is very simple it's a bit like
an e/m but extended to multiple
parameters so what you do you are just
starting with some kind of random
parameter values you fix all of them
except one and then you maximize for
this parameter that you are trying to
optimize and then you take the next
parameter fixing all of them and then
you optimize and then you cycle like
this number of times until you reach
some kind of convergence ok so this
procedure seems to work pretty well and
it allows us to explore ative lee
quickly this describes your space and
actually the parameters in our case we
just need to specify some kind of search
range with a minimum and maximum but
actually this maximum is unbounded and
we can really explore roughly wide range
for all the parameters in our model so
what is also kind of handy with this
program is that it can handle in
principle an arbitrary number of
calculations while that it was
restricted to three populations and so
something I need to mention is that it's
can handle this thing because actually
when we have large number of populations
we are using actually some kind of
composite composite likelihood because
we are just looking at the product of
like causing acute compute between pairs
of populations so we are using just
joints ethnic strife between pairs of
populations and we're just multiplying
all these complete likelihoods we get a
global composite likelihood because just
if you have too many populations than
just these cypresses sex right
itself in multi-dimensions is just
exploding out of billions of entries and
just impossible to estimate all the
entries of this multi-dimensional
sacrifices spectrum so but of course
this imposes have been some penalty but
we didn't find any other way to deal
with this large number of populations so
just some example to show you a bit that
this approach somehow work so actually
we we compared the results we obtained
with passing cloud with some exact
results obtained by chance so he has a
very nice paper in TPP a few years ago
actually derived the SAT practice
spectrum based on some kind of Collison
approach and he solves actually the
cycling season numerically but it's
recipe to cases where you have no
migrations okay so for each kind of
population J demographic model then you
can get a specific expected cycling
section that we can use to compute like
use or what you want okay so i should do
that just in this simple case so we have
tested with different scenarios but on
this exit here you have this relative
error of the site frequency spectrum for
each of the entries of the site freakin
spectrum and just that this is the
density of these errors for this
scenario when we have very short
diversions time of a bit more ancient
vibrations times and of course these
errors are lower if you increase number
of nations from be 1000 when you have
large errors but 2 1,000,000 simulation
for each estimation we're actually the
errors are never larger than factor sent
okay and we have a proxy the same kind
of behavior for this this different
diversions time so and what is also
interesting is that we don't seem to
have any buyers in here with this method
because we have this kind of nicely
symmetrical
distribution around zero okay so in most
instances of what we are going to show
you I used actually 100,000 simulations
to get the expected sir francis spectrum
/ prometric conditions which seems to be
relatively nice compromise between
really accuracy and computing time so
just to show that it work I will just
show you some results I get by
conquering this method with Daddy and
this is for different scenarios the
person is this kind of bottleneck model
where we have the population that
sometime in the past had went through
some kind of bottleneck and then
recovered its size and we won't just to
see these four parameters in this model
the red dots is the true value so it
just simulations so what we did was to
simulate 100,000 sequences of hundred
base pairs of 200,000 short sequences of
10 best day which is about 20 megabytes
of data and we simulated data sets and
for each other said we used 50 runs of
either fast simple to or daddy to try to
recover these estimates okay and he I'm
showing you this box plot represents the
distribution of the point estimates
among these 10 runs so that's a true
value that's the box plot for passing
cloud to and in blue you have box plots
for daddy so we see that the two
approaches seem to reconvert on the
right values that you seem even to have
a bit smaller better distributions for
daddy but actually here just report 90s
of the 10 for that it because in one
case among the 50 runs of daddy no one
could actually seem to converge I just
to remove this case that's that's
something that you have sometimes with
Daddy you had this kind of
convergence problems that you have
really strange results so that's a
different denial I have just a naive
model with two populations actually
migrants at different rates and the
divergent time in the past from an
ancestral population and here I have
these six parameters and again we have
very similar behavior compared to two
daddy but in that case that the only
conversion eight KS out of 10 and the
two other cases are quite bad and maybe
even more complex scenarios this time
with three population which is a bit the
maximum that had Betty can handle at the
time and this model is some kind of soda
model of human evolution where you would
have maybe some population from which to
preparations I've diverged could be you
know some European Asian population that
could be Africa and they could have been
some kind of ancestral bottleneck and we
would like to submit all these
parameters and in that case that's it's
in that our method becomes a bit more
robust and Daddy which has relatively a
wider range of estimated values and even
though in that case again I only show
eight of the ten data sets because the
two others are really awful so in see
that for more complex and I know you
have some kind of limited allocated time
so we just try to use 50 runs for each
daddy estimations then some runs will
never converge and but still among the
one that still seem to converge you can
have raised strange baidu sometimes so
our coefficient for all these seems to
be that our method seems to do at least
as well as daddy for simple cases and in
more complex cases actually it seems to
be a bit more reversed so what is
actually nice with this matter is that
we can extend it to much more complex
scenario than just those I mentioned
before so in that case I just show you
some submissions of we did for some kind
rattling complex model where we have two
continents Island scenario so we have
one continent that sends migrants to
different islands and we assume that we
are sampling genes from each of these
islands and each of these islands
receives different amount of migrants
from this continents and this content
actually was created some time in the
past from one of the islands of this
continent okay and again we're trying to
estimate this migration rate between the
container each of these islands there
okay so it's okay so we are like 12
populations and we are trying to
estimate the amount of migration
received by each of these islands and
the time of this creation of this
continent and the time a progression of
this other continent okay and the red
values are the true ones and again we
did 10 runs and this is the busiest
image we get and I was myself a bit
surprised that we can really recover
these migration rates extremely well
even though they cover will be three
orders of magnitudes and each time for
each of these migration rates we are
having exactly the same search range so
that occurs in this case like five
orders of magnitude for this migration
right so it seems that in this case we
have a matter that can handle wrath of
the complex cases that could be actually
used in real situations so she have any
questions any time just ask okay so
the data in this case sit again it's 20
mega bays it's a seem to be 20 megatons
of data and we have 20 so 10 would be 10
deployed individuals perfect collection
that would be this kind of range yes
need to worry about the order of
optimize the order maximize one
parameter oh yes um in principle not I
mean the people developing this ECM and
greater have checked this and apparently
the order does not matter you cycle
through the ball but yes but always sick
cycle them in the same order and several
times and I usually use like your 50
cycles to get some conversions yes so
the sort of my versions of what we've
been doing in our laps a lot of study
billion frequency correlation at a very
simple summary statistics in trying to
learn that population relationship
papers recently that have tried to
automate the construction of topologies
and demography from this so figure out
how population's unrelated so well
you're here if you doing here is you're
proposing a particular model fitting
parameters of your model yes natural
sort of exciting extension of this which
is to use this as kind of tool that's
actually invented in the search space
liked remix or mixed napper or at least
a graph that actually researches from
topologies and parameterizations that
make more sense exactly so in this case
actually what we've been in a made-up
show you a few examples is that we are
and building that into some kind of
model choice technology so we're just
using this I khakis AIC indices as ways
to validate or to prefer one man over
the other one and following that would
be possible to these kind of things but
we don't have any kind of motivated way
to explore all potential demographic
scenarios and that would involve an
average a number of populations and
Wisconsin spread the service or have
done something related to mess with
revenge yes sure yeah so so I don't know
how much we believe collectively
no sure I mean this is simulated data so
we just show that if you are perfect
data then you can we recover these
things extremely well but then I guess
it's just a question of trying to find a
scenario that would maximize the fit
with your data actually and then I think
we can use this a kakie I think that's
why we propose to use this edgy or some
kind of similar and this is if you have
if you are having some kind of valuation
version you could use these VI co this
job seems to compare models I think just
a question is there another panel where
you've estimated all the island and
continent population I'm just not
showing them or are they given so in
that case we assumed that we knew the
continent sizings and the in this case
is with in this kind of violent content
mouths open of the city to depend
smallest of this Ln parameter right is
it separate yes no we can separate so we
just need to this LM parameter and that
separately and an M ok so we first try
to apply this message e to some kind of
Complete Genomics there when that case
we had like here for populations one
from Kenya Lewis and bantu-speaking
population from from Kenya's and your
parents ECU samples of Yoruba and some
African Americans and in that case we
tried actually to go what to see can we
just actually estimate the initial rate
in Europeans into the
can american population from southwest
of the United States ok so this
population this data is very high
coverage more than 50 X so assume that
we are no error on the SF s and actually
but we extracted some snips from this
asset because we had this constraint
that each name should be at least 5 kb
away from the next one yes to minimize
ND so to dinner some kind of like what
about me to reach 300 do some kind of
interaction yes actually you could
perform you that I guess so it's also
depend how do you get your confidence
and as I shouldn't affect the point
estimates but of course a confidence
intervals you will need to take into
into account the fact that you have a
link linkage between these snips yes and
in case you can reproduce that because
because it a lil frequency correlation
literature let's use on
some people think some people dump in
then there's more sophisticated methods
like this L do like treat sizes on light
people thin people don't fit and I've
never seen anybody convincingly show
that studying is better than so now he
we use this this structure here because
somehow we then treat ed sniffs out as
independent which are they on that but
actually it should be easy to actually
simulate all chromosomes take into
account the distance between the snip
that you have I think that would be
possible okay so that's the scenario we
considered so this is a mob virtually
complex now it's not a she not that's so
we assumed in that case
no no that's all no not not settlement
about other frequencies in any
population just about the locations
where these nibs are found in a genome
so that's stood the sooner we consider
so this looks it complicated but it is
not that much so we just assume that we
have some kind of European continent and
we have actually one island which is the
Cu sample from the Europe that receives
a migrants from this content okay and we
assume then that this continent can has
actually contributed to the initial
formation of this African American
sample but this african-american samples
could also receive the confusion from
some what we call a Niger Congo
relations that's actually as contributed
to the formation of these durable sample
and this video sample okay so we have
this to continent I don't model this is
just because we don't think that it's
directly that you're over that computed
to this sample and it's also really not
is not a rare conductcode you to this
one okay so and and of course this you
can sample as diverse shop some kind of
ancestral African populations and of
course these natural Congo population
continents also has diverged from this
Global African continent and actually
here just show you one of them L that we
evaluated because we also introduced a
nun sample or ghost reputation like
multi introduced yesterday that could be
some Eastern African population that
could have contributed also to select
sent to the gene pool of this lugar in
Kenya okay so won't eat Weston ate all
the writers of this scenario
so looks a bit complex and it's only
displays the killer 10p and all bye
daddy so we got this kind of estimates I
will not really go over all of them but
they seem to somehow make sense for
instance we have this emission rate in
the African Americans which has been
stated of seventy percent which matches
precisely what was it submitted from our
frequencies from steamships actually and
also have this nice also input of maybe
seventeen percent from some potential
East African gene pools into this luya
been to speaking population from Kenya
and we have quite a few other parameters
of that could be interesting question
about interpretation these things are
they are they there's there's no sort of
back arrows in this backyards so
actually has these arrows are NM
parameters yes sir that's a some kind of
iron ore was such that the you have your
balance right yes if it's some kind of
it it's um so this island receives them
this number of genes regeneration from
this speculation okay this our dash
because represent instance and mixture
event that's how we model them so they
are dashed these are the different types
of our roads but designer reserved the
arrows actually just some kind
submission and hem so there's a new
person going the other direction now
there isn't so um yeah um in that case
no no so the population size is a in
fact growing right you know how do you
I can what what's your actual model when
right if you have any sort of in this
case so it's common assumption so we
have some kind of population size here
so genes can increase within this
population or migrate to this
speculation but it cannot come back okay
that's why we don't have arrows in the
other direction actually we just assume
that genes once they reach the
speculation can come back in this
position because we assume it's large
enough so that if this this is neglected
actually now
but of course it has been some chin flow
between the two but we think that we
also assume that there are many earlier
unsampled islands that also contribute
to this continent and actually once you
are on this continent then there is a
very small grated to come back to this
piece so this looks great at least so
what things is a very unconcerned about
the strength there there are some
numbers there I don't know exactly what
they need but that are quite uncertain
so like there's one that's from point O
427 for example where each one raises
one this one here yes that's this
parameter here so we have punish me of
Israel oh but actually the in that case
this NM value could be actually very
large so it could be up to 26 microns
received / generation in this CEO
population your Islands are much larger
than your content like the CEU is larger
than the continent this yeah that
estimate is 38,000 for that right yes
and for 2004 the continent yes yes I
guess I'm like yeah yes it's it's a bit
like yep ok yes
what can I say that interesting in the
40s w give time of generations then this
is six actually that this orange
furniture fixtures are used to somehow
calibrates all the other parameters so
we assume that it was 22 5 e 1812
something like that let's just start the
slave trade actually is impressive that
in the the tiger population size in the
st SW you find your concert interval is
reasonably narrow given that you
probably had very little drift in these
16 generations until you actually think
of this population size in a SW actually
represent a post admixture population or
it kind of a mixture if you want of the
it's an effective parameter it takes
into account they did that divergence
between the source African population
resource European populations it's one
it's difficult to know you know I'm I
think food would be difficult for me to
try to defend any of these parameters
very strong conviction I'm not even sure
that given the complexity of this writer
space that are parameters re correspond
to the exact maximum likelihood this is
a good point because like this is recent
time like you've seen generations
everybody knows that they give a
population size to not 10,000 hours so
its bigger but like the
african-americans in the southwest this
is recent histories we know the sense of
size of these populations has been huge
but my impression is that given this
very short time you don't have much
Collison events during distillation so
consistently we expect yet so it's guess
it's up to 40,000 so it's a bit bigger
but I yes I wouldn't have that much
confidence in this this number so i
think this number is enough perhaps to
prevent any rico in your consent within
this time frame perhaps see i see that's
what it comforts um how its confidence
it's not good it's confidence it's not
there was the enough coalescence
happening there's another lesson to this
madness reading that is the point
estimate outside of the company yes
there is in this that case yet so
because what we are doing we get this
contrast levels by parametric bootstrap
so what we are doing we are just taking
these point estimates generating samples
according to this point estimates and
then resubmitting each time they've come
the parameters and then using this
empirical diversion to get the contents
levels and in that case yes it's a bit
just a suggestion that it might be some
relatives
if you look Lori if you resample yep
really adds up there South African
Americans they might give you relatives
in there that might reduce the Jewish
scholar essences potentially yes no but
no it's it's certainly possible but I
get given this very short timeframe I
wouldn't have anyway the Dougal was most
to see if we can recover this proportion
with wretchedly well and to get under
Prime Minister are they just like
correlated with the population sizes so
like when you have advert a lot of
migration you just don't come any recent
poll essences and so you know my Gration
is all invisible this could be
yes it's the facility as that don't have
a very strong opinions on this so how
much time do I have three minutes for
Matt Simmons so okay so I had also one
part on the estimations of the root
nodules based on different types of data
instead of sequence data may be some
snip chip that was developed with Nick
and David Wright but perhaps i will skip
that maybe to have some it's a wonderful
day the second but emitter that to take
home message is that it's possible to
estimate parameters using this this is a
nice nietzsche we just need to model the
ascertainment which is possible in our
case and maybe just here we apply that
actually to the scenario of diversion
between some yerba and San population
and but I say okay we would like to skip
anyway we have relatively good
consistency between estimations done on
one snip [ __ ] for one sleep panel you
know you're aware of the Sun panels that
I care will maybe skip this because I
just wanted to show you some very
preliminary results that I think also
interesting to to you guys so and this
is the case in that case that could have
been done perhaps with Daddy but we are
trying to look at the case of our
chicken mixture in modern humans okay
and we are envisioning a scenario that
is a bit like this so we will have
actually we have samples from this
Naruto I'll tie so too in video one in
video in bread and we have a scenario
where we have a eurasian population that
would have gone through some kind of
expansion some time ago after going to
bottleneck and this population would
have been unmixed from some potentially
unsampled archaic population that would
have diverged some time ago with this
I'll turn on the top ok that's all
scenario and then we are trying to
estimate this side of the Sun population
the size of this unsampled peculiar
little the census from a little the
ancestral size of humans and littles the
ancestral human proficient size and
deserve a prize ok and for this if you
are using some data set that come from
copley genomics again and I using two
samples so either the Chinese all the
Tuscany sample okay and each time we
estimate furnitures using either one
audio reproduction and so this is I said
we have used only non-coding DNA and
known cpg sites we have used this Altai
not at all and actually at this case
that's something that we are working on
we just use the unfiltered VCF files
sorry we have been discussing these
issues and we again isolated some region
that we're at least 5 kb apart reaching
the funded base pairs and we had like
two hundred seventy two thousand such
regions and we have a bit disallowed of
data on which you are making our
estimations and here we just consider
those sites for which the ancestral
state could be deduced from the 1000
genome there ok so that's a bit let us
say that by going to use and that's the
estimates we get so and in red or orange
we have estimations we get if we use the
chinese sample and in blue if we use the
tuscan example okay so overall we have
extremely good overlaps between the two
types of estimates and these are
ninety-five percent confidence intervals
also for assisting so maybe one question
interest is about the mixture right in
our case we find something a bit
one percent 1.1 one-point-three percent
but in that case we cannot be
distinguished between if there's been
more or less and make sure in one of the
two percolation okay we don't have
enough own okay so that's an interesting
result it fits with some of the previous
estimates that you guys had we have
extremely small confidence interval for
these initial rate and a bit worried
about this oh it's too small but that's
what we have at this stage with this an
asset and another thing interesting that
Maeby's against the what we would have
thought is about the time i visit nature
so and we find extremely recent and mix
your time and and with relatively small
countenance involved as well less than
1000 iterations okay so depending on
what is your favorite estimation of
musician right if you take some assume
different 2 times x minus 8 this points
to estimation two times smaller than
25,000 years if you use a slower one
that i've been wicked it recently it
goes up to 35,000 no it's it's the other
way I assumed rate is 1.3 yes
by the way it points to relatively
recent of time of an extra 25 years it's
interesting it's not obviously different
from the recombination based estimate
but it's very interesting in the distant
right yes yes very quaint and we still
to have an extremely narrow but that
simple so did this seems to be assuming
well estimated and so three point was
some very recent temperature but I'm so
in this case is some point a mistress so
we'd not know if they had beans
continuous admixture from longer period
of time maybe this time could represent
the last event of admixture that's the
kind of thing that we didn't explore yet
so we have of course with now would like
to a bit extend this kind of scenarios
allowing for potential continuous inflow
instead of admixture also allowing the
estimation of also Denisovan
contribution or something that look
would look like the seventh lab the pro
estimation of different initial rate
from effects to modern humans yeah
that's the next steps and I think that
we have this this this possibility to
this content can be done okay so yes a
bit what I wanted to say just that's now
we are working on different things like
some kind of way to use metric Odessa
with these nations we are thinking about
implementing some mcmc
came a bit along the lines laid out by a
woman and Kerrigan and maybe the next
step that that's a bit far-fetched will
be to extend that to within virtual of
your sexy spectrum which seems a bit
more complicated but may not be
impossible to to do okay then some other
crazy ideas about using this potentially
pedigree information to constrain the
question process and let me try to be
able to use those categories to simply
request process through the pedigrees
when we have information on some
pedigrees for some populations like it
so so you use the this conversant comes
as white label story is there any sort
of you know theoretical understanding of
you know our lab will behave the sorts
of models for sure yeah so I think that
Jordan has somehow shown that this
complete likely hood should lead to
Lucia nuts the boy destinations should
be some other clinically which should
maximize at the same position as the
likely actually but of course this way
to explore the space this is a bit
different you know you could have maybe
multiple piece where you have single
pigs in case of two likelihood so I
guess that maybe that's where we have
problems potentially in that this
composite likely surface by happy from
parties and delectable surface and then
might be more difficult to explore
precision on your estimates right yes
yes that's well why we're doing this
kind of bootstrap approach to we are not
relying on some kind of selected ratio
approximation of x square so do when you
read you your bootstrap estimates that's
still done with your condoms it like you
write your model of African history have
this population did you purposefully
introduce a population no but we compare
this model without discos population and
this male is significantly better than
the middle without discos population
because there was something strange
about this via population that didn't
mean there were some things in the
cycling state on the way it looked at we
have some bad fit in some parts of this
equation for this population and this
really improves the lab to the other
feet to the observed data and and for
the populations we defeat seemed okay so
we didn't introduce that one last
question I was just trying to get an
idea of how robust the parameter
estimates for example are for example
like if you have the wrong model for
like cryptic migration how parameter
estimates so the effective population
size are or if you fixed like estimated
park-like estimated parameters and then
seeing how you estimate parameters you
fix in the first place like that 16
generations how last night
any ideas of robust man I would have
some kind of intuitions on some of the
branches but I could not guarantee to to
be sure about the influence of Miss
specification or models on the solution
of some of differentials but this
missive specification issue is an
important issue but it is a strongly
model-based inferential framework
lighting all methods of inference of
this kind of problems even this PS MC
things we assume still there with a
single population it don't stress wind
first it seems a bit magical that it can
employ all these cannot repeat changes
but also still it is also strongly
model-based so somehow if you have a
different model than all these
likelihoods in knowing this [ __ ]
somehow wrong as well and how this can
affect the estimates that also is I
think it's the curse of this model based
in France all right